well i counter balance that with 10
pounds of fat
we both had good summers
[Music]
look at this difference here
this is what he looked like a couple
seasons ago this is what he looks like
this summer 10 pounds of muscle has been
an active summer for him
had a baby girl that was born in
september
has a documentary on him that's debuting
on october 10. a documentary yes on him
about what oh about his all season
yes it's going to get debuts on youtube
how long is it
serious
[Music]
so you didn't see the video the tmz
video this summer
of when he was out and a girl
jumped out of her car
and didn't put it in part because she
wanted to get tyler heroes autograph she
was that
fanatical of a fan is that in the
documentary it might be i'm sure it was
on tmz
no who's who's making this it's just
like a like a like
by a film company producing himself he
had he had a documentary crew
following him all summer
all summer
[Applause]
[Music]
4-4
[Applause]
coach poster said
this is one of the guys highly motivated
this summer
[Music]
tyler hero said there's a lot of people
sleeping on me
i'm going to wake a lot of people up
this season
[Music]
worked on his ball handling
that should be the title of his
documentary you're right about that
there's a lot of people sleeping on me
[Music]
[Applause]
oh